the space is not as big as
you told me But how to close it a
littlemore
and it doesn't smell bad right
don't worry come on Sit down
[Music]
I like to look infield
I want her to be a virgin please doctor
What do you think
No it's not  a request that
one is usually made but but it can be
done Well my fiancé I love my
fiancé but the problem with Gino is that
he never ejaculates
when he is with me he has to go to the
bathroom to masturbate
he just doesn't feel like it  For me,
I dig super High sexual
[Music] [
Music] I
feel I
feel sad
But you do all the things that
occur to you
Exactly about the tiger, I
tried to put my finger in it
I already have enough information
about Yasmín's sexual life Generally I
don't convert
I know you're not a counselor or anything
like that, but you're a doctor and
that's what your friends probably talk about
in a meeting or at the bar,
but I don't know why Gino doesn't attract your
attention,
any man gives me  I wish you would
want me virgin or not full is the only
weird